thrilled to be back and the one thing
that i definitely learned
uh
while i was gone for whatever it was two
months or so is how much i appreciate my
partners because i got a chance to watch
him for all those games and and i
certainly do appreciate him welcome back
on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the right-hander kevin gossman he's
got nine wins an era of 1.84 and that
ranks him number one in all of major
league baseball and right away a base
hit for
the majors hits leader adam frazier and
that's not easy to do against kevin
gossman the opposition hitting just 161
against him this season and key brian
hayes batting
i thought you could see it was a
fastball wow
and an edge pitch they don't get the
call and it's first and second tight
zone like you said that's los diaz right
away you get an example you're just not
gonna get a big strike zone and guzman
has walked back-to-back bucks he has
loaded the bases with nobody out and
here comes gregory polanco
slap toward left
there's dickerson with the catch
frazier tags and he will score
and the pirates strike first on a
gregory polanco opposite field sacrifice
fly first and second with one out for
john nagowski he throws swinging the
ground ball wide of third to his left
boston's got it and then he drops the
ball and everybody's safe well he was
thinking about trying to get rid of it
and start a double play he ends up
dropping the ball and not getting
anybody out ben gamel left-handed hitter
the bases are loaded again swing and a
soft grab ball to short near second
running over to tag the bag as estrada
throws the first double play
and the inning is over glozman it wasn't
easy but does get through it with just
that one run scoring on the hill tonight
for the pirates will be will crow take
your fat skits you're going to see a
flat fastball that's mid to high 90s
he's got two types of movement with a
curveball slider and a changeup so wade
goes to first and now your ski will come
up the pitch and strike three got a low
fast ball in the zone and yostremski
strikes out looking one out the one
outweighed still at first and here is
buster posey two and two the count pitch
swing and a miss he
struck him out he went on the inner edge
with the fastball and wilcrow can say
that he struck out buster posey hands
away from the body he swings and grounds
one softly up the middle newman has it
and quickly flips it onto first for the
final out so will crow navigates a first
inning the giants first hit against will
crow tyrell estrada hitting 347
on the ground this will be a pair it'll
tie the game and
they got him it's one to one at this
point
get him in go ahead run in scoring
position for the pirates it's only the
third one to one and here's the one a
swing in the line driving to right base
hit
and yastremski falls down as he picks it
up that'll allow reynolds to score
easily on the rbi single by gregory
polanco he smacks his hands together as
he's driven in both pirates runs today
now runner at second and two outs for
gammel
line drive to right field and that gets
down for gamble and the pirates
score another
gamble the wide turn gets back with two
strikes he rips a single to right to
bring home polanco with two outs and two
strikes at him gamble drives in the run
and the pirates leading three to one
will crow pitching with a 3-1 lead it's
the top of the order for the second time
now
there's a strikeout
pitch
that's uh
number four they got way to go out of
the strike zone a couple times here's
mike yostremski
swing and a miss it gets away from perez
and he'll throw on the first to complete
the strikeout and crow with five of
those well will crowe looking for a
second straight one two three inning
three two and swing and a miss he struck
him out
well crow was behind three oh and he
comes back to strikeout vosler on that
good slider and he's retired seven
giants in a row three to one lead over
the giants looking for more with
reynolds polanco and nagowski coming up
swinging in the miss he struck him out
the uh splitter on the outside only the
second strikeout of the game for kevin
gausman and now gregory polanco who's
driven in a pair of runs tonight 1-0 is
slammed to right and deep gives dremski
back on this one there it goes over the
deepest part of the ballpark
415-foot home run for gregory polanco
el cafe hits his 11th and the pirates
take a 4-1 lead in the fifth adam
frazier waiting for polanco
the fourth walk of the game allowed by
kevin gausman so here is ben gamel
lion drive base hitting the right center
field
it is going to be cut off by yastremski
miguelski
into third and gammel into second with a
double not able to put him away instead
gamble gets a double and puts gaussman
away gabe kepler out to the mound and he
is signaled to the bullpen for brevity
good chance to drive in maybe even two
here with one out
bouncing ball up the middle of base hit
past the drone at infield and the
pirates score two what a night for kevin
newman there's those two rbis for newman
the pirates lead it six to one two run
single pass the drawn in infield right
back through the middle so you could
close the book on kevin gausman's
evening and those are six earned runs
that go in his era the pirates with that
three-run inning now boosting will
crow's chance for his second victory
oh darts down for the strikeout seven
k's nine straight retired by crow faces
a pitcher now brebia
swing and a miss he struck him out and
in the land of the seagulls it is crowe
who rules the roost he has sent down ten
straight giants top of the order comes
up for the third time against will cross
wade has walked and struck out
high and deep to right
it
is
out of here
and lamont wade says we're not done yet
it's six to two lamont way junior with
his tenth home run of the year he is the
eighth giant to reach double figures
in home runs so now you just regroup and
again focus on getting mike kashimsky
here it is and the pitch strike three
call down on the way with a fastball and
he freezes yastremski one out that's
gonna be it when he strikes out
yastremski three times tonight with
buster posey coming up derek shelton
wants clay holmes to come in the game
weekly hit frazier spins throws and gets
buster posey it helps to have a 34 year
old catcher running the first and
frazier makes a nice ranging play to get
the out going the extra mile to really
range on that slowly hit ball and two on
two outs laura's at second duggar at
first giants have their own power hitter
coming up darren ruff
swing in the miss he struck about with
that curveball down and in stratton
strikes out three in the inning three
hits for kevin newman michael perez
runner goes and perez it's a drive to
right center field
and it is over the head of yastremski
and stays in play
cora going to wave home newman
and the throw
to third is
safe a trip trip
triple for perez and a 7-2 pirates lead
first career triple
for michael perez
defoe with an rbi chance here yeah defoe
sends one to deep left
caught by dickerson here comes
perez to score on the sacrifice fly the
pirates lead at eight to two two hits
tonight for adam frazier and the pirates
try to start something going again here
in the eighth
it hard another hit and another rebbe
for
b-ray
brian reynolds second hit on base for a
third time brings home frasier pirates
lead nine to two in san francisco what
is gabe kapler going to do to pitch the
ninth inning he's going to go to mike
clarkman two on kevin newman 15 hits for
the pirates tonight
make it 16 and a season high and for
kevin newman it's a four hit game
another run in it's a laugher in san
fran ten to two pirates not away from
shaking hands
and
to third baseman key brian hayes raised
the jolly roger pirates with an easy
10-2 victory